are you doing a voiceover for the
American one punch man okay oh yes I'm
uh I'm Boros so this side time would you
like the main yeah guy then uh the main
villain for season one was the last guy
yeah the last guy that he fights is more
zss me guy with one eye yeah I'm Shea
like you do people ever compare you to
uh the cats just you can I don't I can
do all the time like I'll be walking I
didn't do it looking at me and I'll be
walking a bike got cam I'm sure I'm sure
oh yeah I didn't want to drop weight I
get like I get sour reasons I get Tyrese
I've gotten Jeff got 99 if you're
[ __ ] black and you gonna hate your
every single black celebrity that way Oh
Michael Jackson options you know Michael
Jackson dead and he's white now right oh
my god Barack Obama's got all different
shades of black we're not even sure
where it is Hugh I know
expecially when I go different places
like muffins I just wanted to hey Obama
uh okay you know sometimes it comes out
of just people want to connect with
children it's like I get it yeah I
wonder I always wanted this too because
you're an actor you're a martial artist
too sure yeah awesome black so it's like
do people say like are you trying to be
the next money white yes I get that all
you know I'm a number two i'ma tell you
I never tell anybody this huh I would I
was gonna die with the secret but you
know what
so what like one of my first movies that
I love to watch
like Ali know we love blade before blade
was like spa yes come on move spawn and
then when I was a kid I changed my name
to J I really ain't from Michael JAMA
yes I changed money so I kind of stole
stole it from but I actually met Michael
John right a couple times how is he
you know what he's actually a cool do um
he doesn't let him remember me but I
yeah we have a couple of mutual friends
do we change through and it was funny
because we were just watching the fight
the first time I met him was at 87 of
them I remember JJ Perry's a famous
stunt guy he is a hey Chris J come on
over meet Michael John wife and I'm like
you know and I'm trying I'm trying to be
cool you know like here I'm idolizes man
so I don't want and like it's kind of
the big league so you can't go and be
like do all of your [ __ ] cuz I've oh I
can't bring this doing all set yeah how
to act so I'm like oh there's a lot
right it's all like hey nice to meet you
nice and you know enough I can't really
spell your name but he's like yeah go
away hey nice to meet you are cool and
then went back to training I know I
think you might have took it as like
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah you wash
Nick I'm trying to wash it ya know hey I
hope you didn't take it that way but I
was just like to him like you didn't
know you're like this little school - oh
my god I'm a [ __ ] model down wow you
Mary oh okay sure thank you let see
little out at that is like Danny
no no he's like Bing bow my kid said big
mouth oh yeah race his ass kid